bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux la première nouvelle dont je
veux vous parler c'est évidemment ma
présence en France pour une fois je
serai en France le mercredi 8 février et
je donnerai une conférence à 19h au pub
le docteur d je serai en compagnie de
mon collègue local chercheur à Grenoble
au synchrotron de Grenoble Vincent
Fernandez qui lui aussi est
paléontologue dont tous les deux nous
allons faire des conférences sur nos
recherches respectives donc n'oubliez
pas mercredi 8 février 19h au peuple au
pub grenoblois le docteur d arrivée
recommandé à 18h30 si vous voulez être
sûr d'avoir une place assise et puis je
vous laisse un petit commentaire épinglé
en dessous de cette vidéo pour vous
tenir au courant si jamais il y a des
changements mais normalement ça devrait
pas bouger mercredi 8 février à 19h
venez nombreux on continue avec les
petites annonces les petites riviales
les petits faits divers de de la
paléontologie avant d'attaquer la grosse
recherche donc déjà Kevin padiian dans
la revue nation nous rappelle que la
découverte enfin l'annonce officielle de
la découverte du premier dinosaure non
naviens à plumes parce que sinon on va
me sortir l'archéoptérix donc l'annonce
de la découverte du premier dinosaure
non navien a plume c'était mesdames et
messieurs il y a 25 ans il y a 25 ans
1998 champion du monde et
sinosoroptérix premier dinosaure non
naviens à plume découverte et qu'elle
découverte regardez les plumes étaient
si bien préservés regardez ce petit
duvet là qu'il a sur le dos c'était si
bien préservé qu'on n'arrive même à voir
les rayures sur sa queue donc vous voyez
quand on vous dit de quand on vous
demande des grandes preuves vas-y des
pour faire des grosses hypothèses faut
faire faut donner des grosses preuves
bah là regardez l'interprétation de ce
petit fossile là elle ne laisse aucun
doute sur le fait que ce machin c'est un
dinosaure théropode pas encore un oiseau
on voit la taille des bras et est assez
chétive
et ça ne laisse aucun doute sur le fait
que il est couvert de plumes donc à
l'époque il a fallu sortir des grosses
preuves pour montrer que même les
dinosaures n'en avaient des plumes et ce
fossil c'était vraiment le fossile
parfait pour commencer donc voilà
c'était déjà il y a 25 ans ça fait 25
ans maintenant que la Chine nous abreuve
de ces magnifiques dinosaures en plus
mais
on continue avec les trivias avec un
paléontologue accusé de falsifier des
données sur l'astéroïde qui a donné qui
a tué les dinosaures alors vous le
connaissez ce paléontologue j'en ai déjà
parlé pas mal de fois son nom c'est
Robert De Palmas Robert De Palmas il est
connu j'en ai parlé par exemple sur les
T-Rex parce que c'est lui qui avait
publié la découverte d'une dent fichée
d'une dent de T-Rex fichée dans une
vertèbre d'adrosor vous voyez la preuve
ultime que T-Rex était un prédateur
c'est une bande de T-Rex fiché dans une
vertèbre dadrosor et qui a cicatrisé ce
qui montre que du coup enfin la vertèbre
d'adrosa pas la dent la vertèbre
d'adrosa à cicatrisé autour de la dent
ce qui veut dire que la drosaure était
vivant ce qui montre que le T-Rex était
prédateur bon bah ça c'était de Palma et
de Palma c'est aussi lui on en a parlé
pour sur la vidéo le dernier jour des
dinosaures pas ce documentaire là
l'autre celui qui est bien
il y a un documentaire qui s'intitule Le
dernier jour des dinosaures qui est bien
je vous mettrai dans la description et
en gros ceux de dans ce documentaire bah
c'est tout tout un documentaire en fait
sur le site que de Palma étudie qui
s'appelle Tanis et qui est littéralement
un dépôt qui s'est formé le jour de la
mort des dinosaures enfin le jour de
l'extinction massive fin Crétacé début
Paléogène le jour où l'astéroïde est
tombé voilà c'est ça s'est formé à ce
moment là et il développe dans ce
documentaire évidemment des preuves
l'épreuve étant essentiellement
d'origine géologique et donc dans c'est
lui qui a étudié ce site dont je vous
invite à aller voir la vidéo
correspondante si vous voulez en savoir
plus si vous en avez jamais entendu
parler mais bref c'était lui et donc un
des multiples articles qui est la
publier sur le site de Tanis
aurait contiendrait des données
falsifiées en tout cas c'est une
accusation qui a été faite par 7
personnes ici
Mélanie during
donc Mélanie during accuse de Palma en
fait d'avoir falsifié des données afin
de lui enfin basiquement il travaillait
sur la même chose sur le site de Tani ça
savoir les
démontrer quand la météorite est tombée
quand dans l'année la météorite est
tombée vous savez enfin si vous avez
suivi Paléo news je vous ai déjà parlé
du fait que De Palmas et Mélanie during
pense et leurs équipes respectives
pensent que la météorite en fait est
tombée au printemps en tout cas au
printemps de l'hémisphère nord et que
c'est une des multiples causes qui a
causé la gravité de cette extinction
vous voyez vu que c'est tombé au
printemps c'est la saison de
reproduction il y a plusieurs données
qui indiquent ça il y a les pollens il y
a les poissons aussi le ils ont des
poissons qui sont encore gravides ce qui
montre qu'on était au printemps donc
bref il y a différentes données qui
s'alignent assez bien pour montrer que
la météorite est tombée en printemps ce
qui aurait causé ce qui aurait été une
des multiples sources de la gravité de
cette extinction puisque c'était en
plein dans la saison de repos
ce à quoi je j'ai répondu à l'époque
dans mon Paléo news oui mais
l'hémisphère sud
faudrait peut-être pas oublier qu'il y a
un hémisphère sud sur la terre et que
dans l'hémisphère sud c'était l'automne
et pourtant la enfin les conséquences de
cette extinction de masse par définition
vu que c'est une extinction de masse se
sont fait aussi ressentir dans
l'hémisphère sud ça rend pas la chose
plus robuste on va dire ça la rend pas
plus fragile non plus puisque l'un comme
l'autre vous voyez elle qui accuse de
Palma d'avoir
falsifié ces données arrive à la même
conclusion donc ça change rien à la
conclusion au final mais ça ça reste
quand même assez assez bizarre qu'ils
aient conclu que c'est à cause de ça que
l'extinction ait été aussi grave
vu que il y a un hémisphère sud à notre
planète comme toutes les planètes bref
donc l'idée en gros c'est que ça change
pas trop la science c'est vraiment juste
un drama quoi c'est juste un drama et on
personnellement j'en pense pas grand
chose à part je vois pas vraiment
l'intérêt d'avoir pointé ça du doigt
enfin je vois pas vraiment l'intérêt
pour elle de pointer une falsification
des données par deux Palmas dans la
mesure où ça l'a pas empêché de publier
son article dans une meilleure revue en
fait elle elle a publié dans Science il
me semble en tout cas c'est ce que dit
cet article si je me rappelle bien alors
que de Palma lui a publié dans sa
scientifique report qui a un impact
factor inférieur à celui de science vous
avez pas besoin de savoir ce que c'est
l'impact factor c'est juste que c'est
moins prestigieux ça veut juste dire que
c'est moins prestigieux donc elle a
publié ses données dans une meilleure
revue que lui donc au final ça n'a pas
empêché de publier ses données et ça
voilà donc je sais pas vraiment pourquoi
elle l'accuse d'avoir essayé de d'avoir
essayé de le de la de lui couper les ABS
sous le pied au final et donc la
falsification des données pour pour dire
exactement c'est juste en fait le fait
qu'il y ait certains graphes qui sont
bizarres voilà c'est ce qu'elle dit elle
dit il y a certains graphes qui sont
bizarres ce à quoi de palmar a répondu
oui ils sont bizarres parce que le mec
qui travaillait sur les graphes est mort
pendant la rédaction de l'article et
qu'on a pas pu récupérer ses données et
là tu as un silence gênant
donc pour l'instant l'affaire l'affaire
qui a éclaté alors c'était j'ai
téléchargé ça c'était début décembre
n'est pas allé plus loin et honnêtement
je pense pas qu'elle ira plus loin parce
que de Palma oui je pense à bien répondu
en disant oui le mec est mort on a fait
ce qu'on a pu avec ce qu'on avait et que
de toute façon comme j'ai dit le il y a
pas eu il y a pas eu vraiment de dommage
significatif causer même s'il y a eu
falsification les dommages n'ont pas été
significatifs puisque ça change rien à
la science et puis que ça change rien à
la carrière de cette dame de cette
demoiselle les deux d'ailleurs sont
étudiants en thèse donc ils sont au même
niveau sur tous les deux étudiants en
thèse il y a c'est pas c'est pas genre
le grand scientifique établi contre la
petite étudiante fragile non ils sont
tous les deux au même niveau de d'études
donc bon bref on verra bien ce que ça
donne mais ça ça a fait son petit bruit
donc je me sentais obligé d'en parler
mais honnêtement c'est vrai que je suis
pas fan de drama comme ça je suis pas
fan de drama mais on continue quand même
avec les dramas avec cet article qui a
été publié tout autour récemment c'est
un des derniers trucs qui est sorti dans
une revue d'archéologie je connais pas
vraiment les revues d'archéologie c'est
le le Cambridge archéological journal
dont je n'ai pas je n'ai pas compétences
pour évaluer le prestige
mais en gros c'est un article qui est
publié en partie par c'est les résultats
des recherches d'un amateur en fait du
moins c'est comme ça que l'article s'est
vendu a été vendu par la presse c'est
les résultats des recherches d'un
amateur qui a passé très longtemps à
regarder des images de peinture murale
et qui a remarqué en fait qui avait des
petits points des petits traits un peu
partout et donc il en a déduit que ça
pouvait être un espèce de protosystème
d'écriture ou de protosystème numérique
qui servait en fait à calculer le nombre
de mois lunaire pour indiquer
pour chaque animal la période de
reproduction en moi lunaire
donc c'est une découverte si c'est vrai
c'est une découverte qui est assez ouf
parce que ça veut dire non seulement
qu'on a déjà un système de protocole de
proto-écriture mais en plus on a enfin
de proto-écriture dans le sens système
de communication écrite mais en plus ça
veut dire qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
une connaissance de de l'astronomie
puisque c'est des mois lunaires et une
connaissance de la biologie des animaux
qui qui chassaient donc ça évidemment le
l'intérêt de connaître les périodes de
reproduction des animaux que tu chasses
ça permet de gérer les cheptels en
quelque sorte si vous connaissez les
périodes de reproduction vous n'allez
pas surchasser les femelles et ainsi
permettre aux troupeau de se renouveler
et l'année d'après avoir toujours des
des proies en abondance
donc là on aurait une connaissance de
l'astronomie de la biologie de la
gestion de troupeau etc c'est une énorme
hypothèse qui est faite ici mais mais
alors je vais pas les les objections que
je m'apprête à faire ne sont pas les
miennes ce sont celles de Jean-Louis
Lequellec qui est un vrai expert
contrairement à moi je ne suis pas un
expert en peinture murale mais
Jean-Louis le Québec a quand même émis
de gros de grosses réserves quant à cet
article et notamment le fait que déjà
certains des éléments qu'il compte
autant là vous voyez sur la première
figure il y a des points il y a un
nombre de points bien spécifique qui
peut désigner le nombre de mois vous
voyez un deux trois quatre cinq six il y
a 6 points qui désigneraient six mois
lunaire donc ça voudrait dire que cet
animal
se reproduit au bout de 6 mois lunaire à
partir d'un moment donné là le poisson
il y a un deux trois tâches donc ça veut
dire trois mois lunaire après une
période donnée bref
Jean-Louis Le Quellec a pointé du doigt
quand même que autant pour ça ça marche
autant pour ça là ça marche beaucoup
moins bien là arrivé enfin compter ça
comme étant la même chose enfin compter
c'est très en forme de Y comme étant
exactement la même chose que c'est ce
qui sont des points définitivement ici
et des espèces de barre ici c'est quand
même assez douteux
particulièrement quand ils font
définitivement partie du dessin vous
voyez comme ici là ça fait
définitivement partie du coût de
l'animal et donc ça c'est déjà le
premier problème et le deuxième problème
c'est que pour arriver à ce résultat là
d'après Jean-Louis lequelc encore une
fois je vous mettrai je vous mettrai son
article dans la description histoire que
vous puissiez voir toutes ces critiques
parce qu'il en a beaucoup je vais vous
donner que les deux qui moi m'ont le
plus convaincu mais il y a beaucoup de
critiques qu'il a fait à propos des
données qui sont présentées dans cet
article mais en gros voilà il a il s'est
limité du coup
aux tâches et au trait et au marqueur
qui vont entre qui ont entre 1 et 12
marqueurs en fait
et le faire enfin 13 marqueurs puisque
c'est des mois lunaires ils sont un peu
plus courts que les mois que ils sont un
peu plus courts que nos mois du
calendrier du calendrier qu'on utilise
donc il s'est limité à
aux tâches ou au trait qui n'allait que
par que par nombre de 13 ou moins donc
s'il y avait très stage ça allait par
contre quand il y avait plus de 13
stages il les a exclus du jeu de données
enfin ils les ont exclus puisque il est
pas tout seul quand même ils sont
plusieurs à s'y être mis quand il y
avait plus de très stage ou plus de 13
points ou plus de 13 Straits mais en
fait ils les ont exclu du jeu de données
et Jean-Louis lequelc en fait la liste
et c'est embarrassant de voir la
quantité qu'ils ont exclu la quantité de
données qu'ils ont exclu pour qu'en fait
ça rentre dans un tableau à 13 mois
lunaire donc c'est
oui je suis d'accord avec Jean-Louis
lequelex ça ça sent pas bon ça sent pas
bon faut s'en méfier c'est pas et en
plus c'est pas la première fois que
quelqu'un propose ça en fait c'est à
dire que ça a été par la presse comme
étant super nouveau super
révolutionnaire moi même je me suis
emballé dessus si vous me suivez sur
Twitter vous m'avez vu partager le truc
en disant waouh si c'est vrai ce serait
super intéressant
mais il faut bien dire les choses comme
elles sont ça a peu de chance d'être
vrai et et l'une une autre bonne raison
pour laquelle ça peu de chance de d'être
vrai c'est que ça fait longtemps que ça
a été proposé comme hypothèse et que
c'est pas plus vrai en fait ça a déjà
été exclu dans les années 60 et c'est
pas plus vrai maintenant que ça ne
l'était dans les années 60 voilà
donc donc bon voilà je vous mets
l'article de Jean-Louis lequelc dans la
description juste que pour que vous
puissiez lire ce que Jean-Luc le Québec
à dire sur le sujet parce que mon avis
en tant que non expert ne vaut pas grand
chose je trouve juste que le Québec a
des arguments quand même assez percutant
et assez efficace contre contre cette
interprétation mais comme je le dis si
c'est vrai ça voudrait dire quand même
qu'il savait beaucoup de choses sur
l'astronomie sur la biologie etc etc
chose qui sont pas non plus
extraordinaires je veux dire on s'attend
quand même à ce que des chasseurs
cueilleurs sachent ces choses là mais ça
reste quand même ça resterait vachement
intéressant si ça l’était on continue
toujours avec les choses très débattues
très très discutés qui ont fait le buzz
mais pas forcément positif avec cette
annonce
le tyrannosaure vous l'avez certainement
vu passer sous ce titre là les
tyrannosaures étaient malins comme des
singes était intelligent comme des
babouins les dinosaures étaient
intelligents comme des babouins des
titres un peu plus tassiers comme ça bon
bah tout ça ça vient de cet article de
la neurologue Suzanne Susana herculano
Uzel dont on avait déjà parlé alors
j'avais déjà parlé de Suzanna herculano
Uzel parce que à la base elle
travaillait sur les promossiliens donc
on avait parlé d'elle sur la vidéo Paléo
neurologie des propositions et elle
avait donc on avait parlé de cet article
là déjà en particulier avant qu'il ne
soit publié parce qu'il était accessible
en prêt print
on en avait parlé dans la vidéo sur le
tyrannosaure donc là toute la biologie
du tyrannosaure
j'avais discuté entre autres du nombre
de du nombre de neurones qu'il y avait
dans la petite tête d'un tiroir enfin la
grosse tête mais la petite boîte
crânienne date tyrannosaure donc j'ai
déjà fait une critique assez complète de
cet article là mais bon je vais vous la
réexpliquer très rapidement maintenant
mais je vous invite très franchement à
aller voir la critique plus complète que
j'ai déjà faite de cet article là dans
la description donc cet article il nous
dit les théropodes les dinosaures
théropodes avaient un nombre de neurones
telencéphalique équivalent à celui des
primates tel encéphalique ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que c'est le cerveau
mais on exclut le cervelet et toutes les
structures en fait qui savent pas à
réfléchir tout votre votre cerveau
entier ne sert pas à réfléchir il y a
certaines structures qui ne servent pas
à réfléchir le cervelet c'est de la
c'est essentiellement de la coordination
motrice
l'hippocampe etc les structures qui sont
très à l'intérieur qu'on appelle on
appelle ça
généralement en langage en langage
courant on appelle ça le cerveau
reptilien même si c'est faux appelez ça
un serveur reptilien mais c'est le
cerveau qu'on a c'est la partie du
cerveau qu'on a en commun avec les
reptiles en fait cette partie du cerveau
là elle est quasiment complètement
dépourvu de structure qui permettent de
réfléchir en fait il y a beaucoup de
glandes par exemple il y a des glandes
il y a la glande pinéale il y a
l'hypothalamus etc ça sert pas à
réfléchir c'est il y a même pas de
neurones là-dedans donc la partie
télencéphalique du cerveau c'est la
partie qui sert à réfléchir donc chez
nous elle inclut notamment le néocortex
donc tout ce qui est cortex cérébral de
manière générale et on exclut les bulles
olfactifs et on exclut tout ce qui sert
pas à réfléchir
donc ce nombre de neurones tels
encéphalique celui qui sert à réfléchir
chez les théropodes si on en suit
herculano Usel serait le même que chez
les primates et donc ça immédiatement
quand on vous dit ça ça veut dire waouh
les théropodes les notamment
Tyrannosaurus rex qui en fait partie
était intelligent comme des singes et
c'est exactement ce qui est illustré un
peu plus bas il y a beaucoup de graphes
il y a beaucoup de choses comme ça mais
c'est exactement ce qui vous a illustré
ici donc voilà le nombre de neurones
augmente quand on va vers la gauche ici
vous avez le chimpanzé ici vous avez le
babouin et tyrannosaure vous voyez il
est entre les deux il est moitié entre
le singe enfin le babouin et le
chimpanzé ça veut dire qu'il était super
intelligent et c'est là qu'il faut faire
attention
c'est là qu'il faut faire attention
nombre de neurones égal intelligence est
une équation fausse nombre de neurones
égal intelligence c'est ce que le titre
essaye de vous faire croire en comparant
le tyrannosaure avec les singes par
exemple en nombre de neurones nous être
humain avons le même nombre de neurones
telencéphalique qu'une baleine et même
pas une grosse baleine une baleine de
mink c'est à dire qu'une baleine bleue a
beaucoup plus de neurones tels
encéphalique que nous et si
l'intelligence était synonyme de nombre
de neurones telencéphaliques et bah ça
ferait longtemps que les baleines elles
seraient sur la lune ça ferait longtemps
que les baleines nous auraient dépassé
technologiquement ça ferait très
longtemps que les baleines auraient bâti
une civilisation qui qui n'existe à
l'évidence pas voilà donc on a déjà du
mal même à savoir si elle comment elle
communique entre elles si elle
communique entre elles c'est déjà
difficile à déterminer si ne était égal
intelligence ça se verrait beaucoup plus
enfin du moins si on peut considérer la
communication comme étant un phénomène
lié à l'intelligence évidemment mais
bref là où je veux en venir c'est que si
le nombre de neurones égal intelligence
il y a rien d'évident en fait dans ce
lien il y a absolument rien d'évident si
normalement évidemment quand on se dit
ouais nombre de plus tu as de neurones
plus tu es censé être intelligent oui
mais ce serait ce serait négligé un truc
qui s'appelle la taille du corps et
c'est exactement ce que fait herculano
Uzel dans cet article herculano ou zèle
néglige complètement la taille du corps
elle prend le nombre en fait elle prend
la taille du cerveau de Tyrannosaurus
rex tel que préservé par des moulages
endocriniens donc la taille en fait
finalement le volume de la boîte
crânienne c'est même pas le cerveau
lui-même c'est le volume de la boîte
crânienne qui contenait le cerveau
et d'après le volume de la boîte
crânienne elle en déduit que étant donné
que c'est une grosse boîte crânienne bah
on doit pouvoir mettre beaucoup de
neurones dedans c'est c'est plus
compliqué que ça mais je vous simplifie
mais en gros plus vous avez une grosse
boîte crânienne plus vous pouvez y
coller de neurones et donc plus vous
êtes intelligent c'est normal pour enfin
si on suit cet article ce serait normal
et c'est vrai que ça a du sens en soi si
quand je vous l'explique comme ça ça a
du sens oui mais c'est négliger le fait
qu'on ne s'attend pas à ce qu'un gros
animal est autre chose que des gros
organes comme les baleines par exemple
les baleines ont sont des gros animaux
on ne s'attend pas à autre chose
qu'elles aient des gros cerveaux et on
ne s'attend pas à autre chose que de
voir beaucoup de neurones dans ces gros
cerveaux mais ça veut pas dire pour
autant que nombre de neurones égales
intelligence encore une fois si les
baleines si nombre de neurones étaient
égales intelligence ça ferait 2 millions
d'années que les baleines auraient dû
atterrir sur la Lune
et bon évidemment faudrait encore que
les baleines et la moindre motivation à
aller sur la lune mais bon après tout
Homo sapiens n'a pas plus de motivation
qu'une baleine à vouloir aller sur la
Lune
soyons tout à fait honnête donc bref là
où je vais en venir c'est que l'erreur
l'erreur qui est commise ici à mon avis
et la raison pour laquelle cet article
est publié dans Journal of comparatif
neurologie et pas dans nightcher ou dans
sa science c'est un c'est un peu enfin
c'est un grand journal de neurologie
c'est un journal de neurologie assez
connu JCN mais c'est pas non plus Saiyan
sonitcher et la raison pour laquelle il
a été rejeté de sciencecher c'est déjà
ce que j'avais dit dans dans la vidéo
sur le T-Rex c'est qu'à mon avis
négligeait le fait que des gros animaux
vont forcément avoir des gros organes
c'est un problème c'est un problème
et comme je l'ai dit la comparaison
immédiate avec les primates et
fallacieuses là c'est clairement c'est
on essaye de vous induire à penser que
nombre de neurones égal intelligence en
faisant ça
alors qu'on aurait pu comparer
Tyrannosaurus à d'autres animaux qui ont
le même nombre de neurones estimaient
donc pourquoi les primates en
particulier parce que parce que
intelligence parce qu'on veut vous
induire vers parce qu'on veut vous
conduire vers cette conclusion que
nombre de neurones égales intelligence
voilà on essaye un peu de guider votre
raisonnement en faisant ça donc voilà
pourquoi à mon avis cet article il va il
se fait en ce moment rôtir sur Twitter
et voilà pourquoi à mon avis on va pas
vraiment retenir cette chose alors oui
c'est à la mode de dire que les
dinosaures étaient plus intelligents
qu'on ne le croyait dans les années 50
mais en même temps c'est normal ça c'est
la science qui progresse il n'y a aucune
preuve dans le registre fossile de que
les tyrannosaures pouvaient faire les
choses que les primates font aujourd'hui
ça c'est ça c'est assez clair à part
peut-être communiquer comme je dis il se
bouffer le nez il se bouffait le nez
donc il communiquait en se bouffant le
nez mais
les tyrannosaures faut pas oublier
qu'ils ont aussi une biologie très
rapide pour des animaux de cette taille
ils étaient adultes à 13 ans et
mouraient à 30 ans c'est pas non plus
c'est pas un terreau fertile en fait
pour développer de l'intelligence un
mode de vie comme ça c'est il y a
beaucoup d'énergie en fait qui sont
dédiées à la croissance simplement à la
croissance et pas beaucoup d'énergie du
coup qui peuvent être tournés vers le
cerveau et évidemment il faut rappeler
le Tyrannosaurus Rex a quand même un
cerveau qui est tout petit comparé à la
taille de son corps regardez un
chimpanzé c'est un cerveau de 600 g pour
une taille de corps bon bah voilà 1m20
quoi un petit 50 kg un petit 40 50 kg et
pour le même poids de cerveau ou même
pas la moitié de taille de cerveau chez
tyrannosaure tient dans un corps qui
fait celui de la taille d'un éléphant de
5 tonnes 5 à 7 tonnes
donc vous voyez la moitié du cerveau
d'un chimpanzé dans un corps qui fait la
taille de celui d'un éléphant et on
n'est pas sur les mêmes rapports en fait
on n'est pas sur la même échelle faut
avoir un gros corps ça implique aussi
d'avoir plus de neurones pour gérer ce
qui se passe dans le corps et notamment
alors le cervelet va se charger de la
coordination motrice ok mais le la
partie corticale du cerveau la partie
télencéphalique elle va aussi recevoir
tout ce qui est un flux sensoriel
notamment un tyrannosaure ça avait une
très grande surface de peau et tout ça
ça part dans le dans la partie
sensorielle qui est gérée dans le
télencéphale donc c'est un exemple des
multiples raisons pour laquelle on
s'attend pas non plus à ce qu'un gros
animal et autre chose qu'un cerveau
relativement gros mais même de ce point
de vue là en réalité le même de ce point
de vue là en réalité tyrannosaure il est
il a plutôt un cerveau
exceptionnellement petit pas
exceptionnellement gros
voilà tout ce que j'ai à dire là dessus
et évidemment il y a la dernière chose
qui est à préciser c'est que les données
brutes de tout ça ce sont des endocrânes
de tyrannosaure et qu'un endocrin de
tyrannosaure certes ça fait entre 300 et
400 g mais à un endocrin de rhinocéros
ou d'hippopotame ça fait aussi entre 300
et 400 g
donc si on mettait un hippopotame
là-dedans dans cette machine dans ce
calcul que herculanozel a fait pour
estimer le nombre de tailles de neurones
est-ce qu'on en conclurait aussi que les
hippopotames et les rhinocéros sont
aussi intelligents que les primates
et si on faisait on sait aujourd'hui on
peut compter évidemment le nombre de
neurones qu'il y a chez un hippopotame
et un rhinocéros et on le sait que ça
n'atteint pas le niveau des primates ok
d'accord mais si on utilisait la méthode
de herculanosell en faisant mine de pas
savoir combien il y a de neurones chez
un chez un hippopotame ou un rhinocéros
est-ce qu'on en déduirait pas que
l'hippopotame et que les hippopotames et
les rhinocéros sont aussi intelligents
que les primates
à mon avis vu que la vue que les données
qu'on rentre à la base c'est juste
taille de la boîte crânienne à mon avis
on aurait du mal à pas faire cette
erreur donc voilà toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles je me méfie de cet
article
et pour laquelle beaucoup de monde de
manière générale se méfie de des
conclusions de cet article
on va pouvoir enfin commencer avec les
Paléo news générales on va dire pas les
pas les dramas pas les trucs qui font
scandale les vrais les bonnes news la
bonne science avec un article qui est
sorti dans Journal RT bright pale et
anthologie
publié par David hone et son équipe qui
sont des grands qui sont des grands
paléontologues des dinosaures et qui
nous annoncent donc la découverte d'un
petit résidu de mammifères dans un
squelette du théropode Microraptor donc
voilà le petit résidu de mammifère ici
c'est une main qu'on reconnaît bien avec
son compte son nombre de phalanges en
fait les mammifères ont un nombre de
phalanges très très bien définis voilà 1
2 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 qui sont
typiques des mammifères et donc on
arrive à identifier cette main comme
appartenant à mammifère et cette main se
trouve logée dans la cavité stomacale
donc dans l'estomac d'un fossile de
micro rap micro Raptor de Chine
évidemment du Crétacé de Chine et ça ça
mesdames et messieurs c'est la première
fois de l'histoire de la paléontologie
écoutez bien c'est la première fois de
l'histoire de la paléontologie qu'on a
une preuve directe que des dinosaures
mangeaient des mammifères
ça fait le mot dinosaure le mot
dinosaure a été créé par sorry Charles
Owens
en 1842 si je me trompe pas
ou en tout cas dans les années 1840 et
depuis cette époque là on avait jamais
trouvé la moindre preuve que les
dinosaures mangeaient des mammifères que
les dinosaures carnivores évidemment
mangeaient des mammifères vous rendez
compte du truc est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte du truc ça fait quasiment
200 ans en quasiment 200 ans d'histoire
de la paléontologie quand vous avez vu à
la télé dans les magazines un dinosaure
en train de chasser un petit mammifère
et ben on n'avait pas de preuve c'était
une hypothèse
c'était pas une hypothèse déraisonnable
évidemment mais ça n'était qu'une
hypothèse rendez-vous compte qu'on a
découvert répénomamus donc un mammifère
avec des restes de dinosaures dans son
estomac
avant d'avoir découvert un mammifère
dans l'estomac d'un dinosaure on a
découvert je répète on a découvert un
dinosaure dans l'estomac d'un mammifère
du Mésozoïque
avant d'avoir découvert un mammifère
Mésozoïque dans l'estomac d'un dinosaure
je vous laisse cogiter ça c'est de la
folie c'est de la folie donc bravo pour
cet article c'est quand même de la folie
et évidemment micro Raptor était à peine
plus gros que le mammifère qu'il a gobé
et évidemment du coup il ne l'a pas
chassé en meute
une fois de plus un nouveau clou dans la
tombe de l'hypothèse des droméosaures
qui chassent en meute
un autre clou dans la dans l'hypothèse
des dinosaures qui chassent en meute
l'étude des sériesma donc les sériesma
ce sont des oiseaux de proie qui vivent
aujourd'hui en Amérique du Sud ce sont
des oiseaux vivants vous voyez c'est des
photos
ben voilà là ça ça voilà ça Yema c'est
ça donc ce sont des oiseaux de proie
vivants avec un petit toupet là sur le
pif là c'est très joli les mains de très
longues jambes et ils attrapent les
serpents avec leur très longues jambes
et ils les éclate comme ça au sol papa
papa papa
un peu comme des sagittaires en fait et
donc c'est ça y Emma ils ont étudié
parce que ils ont ceci de très
intéressant nos amis les sériesma qu'ils
ont une énorme griffe vous voyez ici ils
ont une énorme grippe sur le doigt
numéro 2 exactement comme les avait les
Raptors enfin les droméosaures du coup
c'est un très bon analogue
fonctionnel au moins ça veut pas dire
qu'ils les ont hérités de leurs ancêtres
Raptor mais c'est au moins un analogue
à comment utiliser comment les Raptors
utilisaient leurs griffes et donc ce
qu'ils ont découvert bah c'est que enfin
du moins ce qu'il décrivent là c'est
qu'en fait les sériéma n'utilisent pas
leur griffes pour lacérer des proies
plus grosses queues
les Raptors qui se jettent là sur le sur
le lait de Montrésor là pour le lacérer
avec leur griffes c'est pas ça qu'ils
font d'ailleurs les griffes des Raptors
ne sont pas du tout aiguisées si vous
regardez bien la griffe de Alan Grant
dans Jurassic Park 1 la griffe elle est
pas du tout aiguisée elle est pointue
oui mais elle est pas aiguisée et donc
griffes qui est pointu et pas aiguisé
devait être utilisé comme celle des
sériesma pour bloquer les proies au sol
en fait c'est ce que ce qui vous est
illustré là donc les sériesma ils
utilisent leur griffes pour bloquer
leurs profs au sol et pour pas qu'elle
s'échappe et donc on parle évidemment de
petites proies donc une fois de plus pas
de la chasse ensemble en tout cas ça
s'applique au moins au petit droméosaure
pas forcément en gros ceci dit il y
avait pas non plus masse de gros
droméosaure au-delà de des nonicules
c'est au-delà de la taille de des
nonicus et du taraptor il y avait pas
non plus masse de grandes Roméo mais au
moins pour tous les petits dromésosaure
maintenant on a quand même un tissu de
preuve qui montre bien que il chassait
des petites proies et pas des grosses et
donc qui n'avait pas besoin de chasser
en meute on reste avec les dinoiseau
moitié dinosaure moitié oiseau avec la
découverte de 7 animal ici qui s'appelle
Kratos et alors Kratos vous en avez
entendu parler probablement dans les
news si vous avez vu passer et un titre
du genre un oiseau avec un crâne de
T-Rex
ouais ouais c'est ça il y a il y a
vraiment des trucs qui ont titré on
vient de découvrir un oiseau avec un
crâne de T-Rex
il y en a qui ont peur de rien il y en a
qui ont peur de rien pour caser le mot
T-Rex absolument partout donc non c'est
pas un oiseau avec un crâne de T-Rex
Krato Navy il est intéressant on va dire
parce que c'est un oiseau qui quand vous
regardez le squelette à définitivement
le squelette d'un oiseau vous regardez
la main par exemple ici enfin le bras le
bras a des doigts complètement fusionnés
les trois doigts de la main sont
complètement fusionnés et il y a pas de
griffe donc comme les oiseaux c'est un
oiseau du Crétacé un kratovis
du moins si je me trompe pas c'est un
oiseau du Crétacé on va regarder ça
rapidement
c'est un oiseau qui vient oui de
crétacer inférieur de Chine voilà donc
c'est un oiseau du Crétacé donc c'est un
oiseau qui a vécu en même temps que les
dinosaures mais il a déjà une anatomie
d'oiseaux en fait son squelette est déjà
celui d'un oiseau donc vous voyez la
main dépourvue de griffes les pattes
arrière avec un bel alu bien opposable
pour saisir les branches exactement
comme un oiseau moderne
vous avez une à Lule sur le la main vous
avez un pigostil et à saint-sachrome
donc le il y a plus la queue et
raccourci donc il y a plus la longue
queue par exemple d'archéoptérix et le
saint sacrum ça veut dire que les
vertèbres du sacrum les vertèbres du
bassin sont fusionnés au bassin lui-même
donc bref vous avez tout ce qu'il faut
pour faire un oiseau si vous regardez le
corps par contre ce qui est intéressant
avec Kratos c'est la tête parce que sur
la tête on a des alvéoles dentaires donc
ce qui veut dire que craona vis avait
des dents et quand on regarde l'os près
maxillaire on y voit on y voit le pif
enfin du moins le se trouvait là le
voyez le si vous remettez l'os en place
ici ici vous avez la narine le pif et
ici vous avez donc une fenêtre c'est le
dernier reste si vous voulez de la fosse
en théorbitaire du plan d'organisation
arcosor que les oiseaux aujourd'hui ont
perdu généralement la cette fausse en
terre orbitaire et fusionnée ici avec
l'orbite et ici vous avez une fausse
supra temporale ici vous avez une fosse
infra-temporale donc le crâne est dit
abside et ici vous avez une absence
entre le nasal et le frontal vous avez
absence d'une articulation celle qui
permet au bec des oiseaux de se soulever
vous voyez que les oiseaux contrairement
à nous qui ne pouvons que baisser la
mâchoire inférieure les oiseaux eux ils
peuvent aussi soulever la mâchoire
supérieure en plus du fait de baisser la
mâchoire inférieure donc ils ont plus
d'amplitude et ça c'est dû à une
articulation qui se trouve ici et lui il
a pas cet articulation donc il a
effectivement un crâne qui correspond à
l'archétype des Théropodes
mais de là à balancé que ça c'est un
crâne de tyrannosaure faut pas déconner
non il a il a un crâne en fait
d'archéoptérix parce que tout ça on le
retrouve dans l'archéoptérix donc on a
vraiment une mosaïque en fait entre un
corps d'oiseau définitif et un crâne qui
fait penser à archéoptérix bien plus
qu'un n'importe quel autre oiseau du
Crétacé en fait parce qu'il faut voir
que déjà au Crétacé on a des oiseaux qui
ont un bec on a des oiseaux qui ont
perdu
qui ont perdu les fausses temporales au
moins celle supérieure bref il est il a
un crâne remarquablement primitif
comparé à son corps et ça on s'y
attendait pas donc c'est pour ça que
craona vis est intéressant c'est pas
parce qu'il avait un crâne de
Tyrannosaurus rex ouais les médias les
médias ils se sont déchaînés pendant le
mois de décembre janvier c'était de la
folie
et pour terminer avec les dinosaures une
nouvelle une nouvelle étude publiée dans
Biology Letters une revue assez
prestigieuse quand on n'est pas les
anthologues qui nous décrit en fait ce
cette
grande carapace d'ankylosaure donc qui
s'appelle alors si vous en avez entendu
parler c'est zoom c'est un de ces deux
ankylosaures qui qui a été retrouvé
quasiment complet et donc ce qu'ils ont
observé sur zoom et ben c'est que les
les
ostéodermes de la carapace donc c'est
grosses écailles là aussi fier qu'on
voit sur la carapace de cette
ankylosaure en fait les ostéodermes qui
sont sur le côté
ont des fractures et ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça veut dire que
ces
ostéodermes ont été fracturés par un
choc venu du côté choc latéral et à
votre avis qu'est-ce qui peut produire
un choc sur latéral sur la carapace d'un
ankylosaure bah évidemment la grosse
massue d'un autre ankylosaure donc là il
nous montre pour la première fois des
preuves possibles que les ankylosaures
utilisaient leur grosse massues pas
peut-être pas uniquement pour se
défendre mais aussi pour pour se battre
probablement pendant la période de
reproduction
ou bien pour établir finalement la
hiérarchie de dominance etc il y a il y
a quand même un petit hic à cette étude
c'est que là vous voyez on nous montre
donc les ostéodermes endommagés sur ces
photos là alors ils sont pas tous super
facile à interpréter mais au moins c'est
de là on voit bien la pointe ici et le
bout de la pointe de l'ostéoderme et ici
pareil le bout de la pointe de
l'ostéoderme qui est cassé il y a pas de
trace de cicatrisation
et donc ça veut dire que les dommages
s'il y a pas de trace de cicatrisation
ça veut dire que les dommages ont pu
être fait après la mort alors que s'il y
avait une trace de cicatrisation ça
aurait été définitivement des dommages
qui auraient été faits à la carapace du
vivant de l'animal donc finalement la
seule chose qui soutient que c'est
possiblement des traces qui ont été
faites pendant un combat que contre eux
voyez ce serait mis tête bêche et bam
bam bam ce serait ce serait défoncé à
grand coup de queue titre
c'est finalement la position latérale
des dommages ce qu'ils disent en gros
c'est que si ça avait été un dommage
post mortem en fait d'autres ostéodermes
à d'autres endroits de la carapace
aurait été endommagé et c'est pas et ce
n'est pas ce qu'il voit le problème
c'est que les l'épreuve sont quand même
un peu maigres c'est un peu maigrichon
il aurait fallu au moins qu'il y ait de
la cicatrisation pour montrer qu'ils
étaient encore vivants après le combat
parce que les les combats pour établir
la dominance ne sont généralement pas
des combats à mort généralement je dis
bien au point de vue de la sélection
naturelle en fait un combat pour
conquérir une femelle vous n'avez aucun
intérêt ni vous ni votre adversaire
est-ce que ce soit un combat à mort on
sort enfin des dinosaures et on passe
maintenant au reptiles marins les
ictyosaures les reptiles marins du
Mésozoïque avec ici un article paru dans
une grande revue sur un biology revue
prestigieuse où on a ni plus ni moins
que les squelettes de cette
ichtyosaure géant du genre
chonisaurus vous voyez ici la surface
qui a été scannée et vous voyez ici
l'interprétation de cette surface donc
il y en a un ici deux trois quatre cinq
six et sept représenté par des couleurs
différentes
donc cette squelettes de chonisaurus
alors shonise pour vous le replacer
c'est un candidat très sérieux au plus
grand reptile marin du Mésozoïque toute
catégorie confondues c'est pas forcément
le plus grand parce qu'il y a des
mosasaure qui qui tiennent la distance
mais c'est quand même et chronosaurus
évidemment qui tiennent à distance mais
ça fait quand même partie du top 5 des
bons candidats au plus grand reptiles
marins qui est jamais existé quoi donc
shonyzaurus c'est un ictusor vous voyez
une petite silhouette ici donc ça fait
partie de ces reptiles marins qui vont
converger vers une morphologie de
dauphins mais chonisaurus n'en est pas
encore là puisque c'est un c'est un des
tous premiers épisodes de la fin du
Trias donc c'est un c'est un des tous
premiers en fait ichtyosaure et c'est
pour ça que c'est pas derrière son corps
presque autant développé que c'est pas
qu'avant et que sa queue vous voyez
n'est pas encore très fortement il peut
serre que comme on le verra ensuite chez
les plus tardif donc ça c'est très
intéressant et ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant donc avec ce déjà vous
imaginez la découverte regardez là ça ça
fait 1m donc là vous allonger quelqu'un
par terre ici en fait sa tête si ses
pieds sont là sa tête est là ça c'est un
être humain là ce que je suis en train
de représenter là avec les ondulations
de ma
[Musique]
[Rires]
on a un événement d'échouage massif mais
on a surtout un événement d'échouage
massif qui a impliqué des juvéniles de
très très très jeunes juvénile regardez
là vous avez la mâchoire d'un adulte ici
d'ailleurs on remarque qu'il y a de très
grosses dents c'est il y a cette idée
que les gros
iquiosaures du Trias se nourrissaient
comme des se nourrissaient en fait se
filtrer était filtreur comme les
baleines d'aujourd'hui parce que on
pensait qu'ils avaient pas dedans mais
en réalité regardez il y a des énormes
dents donc à la limite on a peut-être un
animal qui se nourrissait par succion
comme les cachalots par succion c'est à
dire en pompant avec sa langue des
animaux des grands invertébrés qui
vivaient à l'époque donc ça c'est la
mâchoire de l'adulte vous voyez un
centimètre l'échelle et là vous avez la
mâchoire du petit donc l'échelle là
c'est 5 mm
en fait dans la petite barre d'échelle
ici c'est tout petit petit donc il y a
vraiment des des tout jeunes bébés
ichtyosaure qui était avec ses adultes
quand ils se sont échoués et ça
ça a conduit du coup à l'hypothèse que
bah les bébés itinosaures devaient
suivre les des parents etiosaures qui de
qui eux-mêmes devaient faire partie de
groupe dichtyosaure plus grand alors il
est possible que l'événement des choix
soit dû à une tempête et que ils se sont
tous retrouvés par hasard ensemble ça on
a toujours le même c'est toujours le
même problème avec les assemblages
fossiles c'est que ce sont des
assemblages de Morse ne sont pas des
assemblages de vie donc on sait comment
ça nous montre au mieux comment ils sont
morts mais pas comment ils ont vécu mais
on peut faire l'hypothèse quand même
raisonnable que la raison pour laquelle
ils étaient tous ensemble au moment où
ils se sont échoués c'est parce qu'ils
vivaient ensemble et la raison pour
laquelle il y a des tout petits au sein
de cette assemblage c'est que c'est tout
petit vivait avec eux donc les on a
vraiment un groupe social et l'une des
l'une des choses qui est remarquable
avec ça c'est qu'en fait il y a des tout
petits il y a des gros adultes mais il y
a rien entre deux
ça veut dire que les ça veut dire que
les adolescents devaient se faire botter
les fesses hors du groupe comme chez
certains c'est assez aujourd'hui les
adolescents se font beauté hors du
groupe pour aller rejoindre d'autres
groupes et ça permet à l'espèce
d'assurer un brassage génétique donc ça
c'est ce serait super intéressant si
c'était effectivement le cas une
dernière chose regardez ça c'est une
section à travers les dents du bébé
ictyosaure et regardez comment c'est
comment les mailles et plissé ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve chez le
cellacante par exemple qu'on retrouve
aussi chez certains amphibiens du permis
et du Trias c'est très très marrant de
voir ça chez des ictyosaures et c'est
une structure qui possiblement renforce
les mailles dentaires mais on en est pas
sûr on sait pas vraiment à quoi ça sert
c'est pli mais c'est vraiment superbe de
les voir préserver de cette façon donc
voilà c'est un article qui est quand
même super intéressant parce que ça
suggère finalement encore une fois une
vie antoupo chez les ichtyosaures
d'ailleurs vous voyez que là on est sur
une catégorie de preuves pour la vie
anthropo qui est complètement
différentes de celles de l'ankylosaure
qu'on a vu plutôt c'est pas du tout le
même type de preuve mais ça reste
toujours des hypothèses
raisonnables à partir d'assemblage
fossiles qu'on essaie d'interpréter le
plus justement possible et surtout ce
qui est intéressant avec ça c'est que ça
explique un phénomène marrant c'est que
dans les années 2000 en 2000 c'est en
2011 vous voyez en 2011 il y a un
chercheur qui avait proposé que en fait
les la raison pour laquelle on trouvait
assez souvent des ictyosaures du Trias
donc comme shoniseaurus qu'on trouvait
des
ichtyosaures du Trias dans des
assemblages comme ça c'était parce que
il y avait des Kraken je déconne pas
il y avait des Kraken donc des des
pieuvres géantes qui utilisaient les
vertèbres de ses ictyosores pour faire
des autoportraits vous voyez pour
aligner les vertèbres de telle sorte à
ce que ça fasse comme les tentacules
enfin comme les ventouses des tentacules
d'une pieuvre je ne déconne pas tout est
écrit là vous pourrez aller lire
l'article ce serait un autoportrait de
pieuvre fait en vertèbre en colonne
vertébrale de chonisaurus
[Rires]
donc en fait du coup maintenant on a une
bonne explication cette explication
c'est qu'ils se sont retrouvés
alignés ils se sont retrouvés alignés
parce que ils se sont échoués ensemble
et que c'est le même courant qui les a
amenés au même endroit et il vivait en
groupe et c'est pour ça qu'il y en a
autant on termine enfin avec le
Mésozoïque avec cette nouvelle étude qui
décrit un nouveau pterodactyloïde donc
un proche parent un ptérosaure proche
parent de ptérodactyle découvert en
Allemagne alors il a pas été découvert
un solnofen comme terre comme le
Pterodactyl ou comme l'archéoptérisque
mais dans un dépôt très très similaire
que vous voyez ici c'est aussi du
calcaire lithographique de la deuxième
moitié du Jurassique mais je vais juste
vous montrer je voulais juste vous
montrer mais c'est la finesse de la
préservation du truc donc c'est le même
type de préservation qu'un seul no fun
et donc ce que vous voyez là voilà on a
une autre image avec une lumière
UV si je me si je ne me trompe pas c'est
voyez vous voyez là les deux ailes ici
vous voyez les pattes arrières ici et là
et le crâne se trouve ici et sur ce
crâne vous voyez les dents il a des
centaines des centaines de dents je
crois qu'il y a 400 dents en tout qui
sont alignés et hyper serrés donc là
vous voyez le dessin interprétatif qui
sont très finement alignés et super
serrés et donc bah ça fait penser à mort
à terreau d'austro ça fait vous voyez le
petit le fameux Pterodactyl rose du
livre de biker ça fait penser à mort à
ptérodos trop ça fait penser à mort
aussi à un flamant rose donc c'est
probablement un animal qui vivait
exactement comme les flamants roses qui
vivaient dans la lagune qui a ensuite
formé ces calcaires lithographiques et
dans cette lagune il remuait la vase et
utiliser ses dents pour filtrer les
petits invertébrés de la vase donc c'est
un magnifique exemple de convergence
évolutive avec pterodostro et avec avec
les flamants roses et c'est une c'est
effectivement une convergence avec les
flamants roses parce que les flamants
roses et finalement n'ont pas dedans
alors que là c'est à l'évidence vous
voyez on voit bien que c'est émaillé là
à l'évidence chez ce terreau d'actif ce
petit loïde ce sont des dents donc son
petit nom à lui c'est bye noire natus
donc les mâchoires avec des baleines
donc les baleines ce sont les fans en
fait c'est pas c'est pas les baleines
dans le sens où il ressemble à une
baleine mais les baleines en anglais
balines ça veut dire les fans donc c'est
le les mâchoires à fans en fait son
petit nom veut dire mâchoire à fan
on sort enfin du Mésozoïque et on arrive
maintenant il y a 2 millions d'années au
Groenland ou ce nouvel article dans la
la revue nightcher nous décrit que bah
en fait ils ont pris du sol du Groenland
et dans ce sol du Groenland ils ont
trouvé de l'ADN et comme ce sol date de
2000 elle se sol ce sol gelé du
Groenland
à 2 millions d'années et ben ils ont
découvert ni plus ni moins que le plus
vieille ADN qu'on n'est jamais réussi à
séquencer et ils n'ont pas trouvé qu'un
petit peu d'ADN en réalité ils en ont
trouvé beaucoup vous voyez il y a du
cerf il y a de l'éléphant il y a du
lapin il y a de la fourmi il trouve tout
c'est en fait le sol je l'ai du
Groenland a retenu tous les déchets
organiques des animaux et des plantes
qui vivaient là vous voyez qu'il y a
même des plantes donc tous les animaux
les plantes qui vivaient là qu'ils
soient petits ou grands ont laissé
derrière eux des déchets organiques des
morceaux de peau de cuticules de plumes
de crottes évidemment des excréments et
ça ça a permis du coup à cette étude de
voir le jour de séquencer toutes cette
ADN donc c'est de l'ADN on appelle ça de
l'ADN environnemental c'est ce qu'ils
disent ici parce que on le trouve pas
directement sur les fossiles mais en
réalité on les trouve en faisant des
prélèvements de sol donc des
prélèvements de l'environnement donc qui
l'eût cru en fait que le plus vieil ADN
qu'on puisse retrouver
ne serait pas contenu dans un os ou dans
une structure en dure de manière
générale mais serait en fait contenu
dans la terre ça c'est c'est comme de
l'ADN mais ça se trouve dans la terre et
on a on a trouvé le nom c'est de l'ADN
environnementale donc voilà c'est plus
la curiosité ils ont rien découvert de
nouveau au final ils ont découvert les
espèces dont on savait déjà qu'elles
étaient là ils ont reconstitué un
environnement dont on savait déjà qu'il
ressemblait à ça mais là où c'est
intéressant c'est que ça valide la
possibilité même de l'existence d'un ADN
aussi vieux que 2 millions d'années en
fait c'est ça la grosse news de cet
article c'est que
on peut trouver de l'ADN qui chiffre en
millions d'années donc c'est évidemment
dû au froid c'est pour ça que c'est au
Groenland
on reste dans les latitudes dans les
latitudes glaciales dans les attitudes
polaires les latitudes polaires avec
cette fois une modélisation donc c'est
un modèle informatique qui a été généré
afin de comprendre en fait la dispersion
des animaux entre l'Asie et l'Amérique
du Nord durant la fin de la dernière
période glaciale donc comment les
animaux ont traversé le détroit de
Béring à la fin de la dernière période
glaciaire et en fait ce que cette étude
ce nouveau modèle
propose c'est que quelques en fait le
détroit de Béring n'était pas inondé
quelque part entre 46 000 et 36 000 ans
et ça c'est très très très intéressant
parce que on a trouvé des empreintes
humaines vieilles de 24000 ans en
Amérique du Nord qui ont d'un seul coup
repoussé l'arrivée de l'être humain de
15000 ans à au moins 24000 ans et au
moins 24000 ans ça veut dire
probablement 30 000 ans en réalité 25 à
30000 ans et là en l'occurrence bah
c'est exactement ça qui trouve à savoir
que leur modèle indique que le détroit
de Béring n'était pas inondé pendant une
petite période pendant 10 000 ans quand
même entre 46000 et 36000 ans et ça ça
colle quasiment parfaitement avec ce
nouveau scénario qui a émergé il y a
moins de 5 ans parce que c'était c'était
quand c'était il y a deux ans même pas
qu'on a découvert ces empreintes ça
faisait avant ça les plus vieilles
preuves de présence humaine avec 15000
ans donc on se doutait que peut-être 20
000 ans c'était possible mais maintenant
on parle voilà de on parlait de 250 000
ans et là on parle même carrément de 46
000 à 35000 ans alors après reste une
modélisation les modélisations elles
inclut des phénomènes climatiques des
phénomènes géologiques etc etc
mais une modélisation ça ne vous donnera
pas plus de résultats que les données
que vous rentrez dedans ça peut pas
c'est pas une reconstitution de la
réalité c'est un modèle ça reste un
modèle mais si le modèle est juste et
peut-être interprété de façon fiable
alors on s'attendra effectivement à
trouver des êtres humains en Amérique du
Nord durant cette intervalle de temps
donc on verra dans le futur si ce modèle
est validé ou non par les découvertes
archéologiques et pour finir avec les
mammifères les chimpanzés les chimpanzés
modernes dont l'étude du comportement
enfin l'étude du comportement d'une
population particulière de chimpanzés je
crois que c'est en Tanzanie
montre que les chimpanzés sont très
fortement bipède dans les arbres ouais
c'est ce que vous montre ce graphelin la
bipédie au sol pas tant que ça la
bipédie dans les arbres beaucoup
énormément 86% de 86% du temps passé en
posture bipède chez cette population de
chimpanzé de Tanzanie c'est de la
bipédie arboricole et ça du coup ça a
des implications sur l'évolution de
notre propre vie pédiat nous parce que
vous savez que dans le modèle de liste
side story on est devenu bipède parce
que il y avait plus d'arbres magiquement
c'est le climat c'est asséché il y avait
plus d'arbres et pouf on serait devenu
bipède bon bah ça c'est un modèle qui a
été largement remis en question par la
découverte de la découverte de Toumaï et
donc Toumaï il a été retrouvé dans un
environnement qui était plutôt boisé on
a un scénario avec Toumai ou Toumaï
vivait dans un environnement boisé mais
était déjà bipède et donc là on a les
données sur cette population de
chimpanzé qui montre que ces chimpanzés
là quand ils sont bipède c'est dans les
arbres donc la bipédie arboricole qui
permet de se déplacer de façon un peu
plus safe vous voyez vous pouvez tenir
les branches en l'air et en même temps
marcher sur les branches donc vous êtes
vous êtes stable et ça vous permet
notamment de ramasser pas mal de
nourriture visiblement c'est surtout en
fait c'est surtout pour ramasser la
nourriture qu'ils sont bipède pas
tellement pour se déplacer pour se
déplacer ils vont certainement préféré
se balancer ou la quadrupedy arboricole
mais par contre la bipédie arboricole
c'est pour collecter la nourriture
puisqu'il évidemment vous avez des longs
bras vous êtes vous vous tenez debout
donc vous allez chercher plus loin
autour de vous en fait avec cette avec
cette bipedia arboricole donc ça c'est
un résultat très intéressant parce qu'il
a des implications directes sur notre
compréhension de l'origine et de
l'évolution humaine
et puis enfin on va terminer avec alors
je j'allais dire des invertébrés mais
non c'est pas des invertébrés c'est on
sort carrément du règne animal on va
chez les champignons prototaxie test
prototaxe si vous ne le connaissez pas
c'est un c'est un fossile très
mystérieux du Dévonien c'est un fossile
très mystérieux parce que ça fait ça
peut faire de deux à trois mètres de
long et ça ressemble à une énorme pine
voilà ça a une énorme une énorme forme
phallique de deux à trois mètres de long
et on savait pas trop ce que c'était
prototaxita alors il y en a qui ont
proposé que c'était un gigantesque
champignon qui poussait comme ça sur
deux mètres de 2 3 mètres de haut et
donc dans cette dans ce nouvel article
du Canadien journal microbiology
les deux une cette nouvelle étude
propose qu'en fait prototype n'était pas
un champignon tourné vers le haut mais
qu'en fait prototype était un rhizome
vous voyez un rhizome c'est ça donc ça
c'est exactement la forme effectivement
de prototaxie test juste en beaucoup
plus gros mais c'était un rhizome
c'est-à-dire une sorte de racine de
champignons on n'appelle pas les racines
de champignons on n'appelle pas ça des
racines on appelle ça des rhizomes parce
que Racine c'est c'est réservé aux
règnes végétales ce que ne sont pas les
champignons donc ils ont analysé la
structure interne de prototaxe grâce à
des sections fines ils ont analysé la
géochimie donc la chimie de la
composition de prototaxe et ils ont
trouvé que ça colle quand même pas mal
avec un rhizome de champignons moderne
et donc ils ont concluent que
prototaxites c'était plutôt ça en fait
c'était un genre de de racine de
champignons qui courait au sol et donc
ça explique aussi comment ils arrivaient
à atteindre des tailles gigantesques
c'est qu'en fait ils ont jamais été
vertical ils ont toujours été horizontal
c'est quand même vachement plus facile
de grandir
à l'horizontale que de grandir à la
verticale donc ça c'est c'est
intéressant c'est une nouvelle étude qui
qui mine de rien révolutionne la
compréhension d'un fossile qui était
resté mystérieux jusqu'à présent même si
vous connaissiez pas prototaxites sachez
que prototaxites c'était un des grands
mystères de la paléontologie moderne des
pop-up bon sang mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette truc qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette gigantesque pin du dévonia
et bah c'était c'était un rhizome
c'était un rhizome et pour conclure ce
Paléo news de nouvelles études qui
enlèvent des grosses épines dans le pied
de la théorie de l'évolution le premier
publié dans la revue plus prestigieuse
PNAS PNAS pour les intimes qui résout le
problème de l'origine des protéines
puisque on savait pas trop en fait on
sait pas trop comment les protéines
s'assemblent pour former des chaînes
d'acide aminés donc on a on a
l'influence possible de certains argiles
qui permettent de catalyser le
l'assemblage des acides aminés en
protéines on a proposé les roches
volcaniques très abondantes dans la
Terre primitive permettant l'assemblage
qui permet de catalyser aussi la
l'assemblage de d'acide aminés pour
former des protéines et en fait vous
avez cette nouvelle étude de PNAS dans
PNAS qui nous dit qu'en fait on n'a pas
besoin de tout ça on n'a pas besoin
d'argile on n'a pas besoin de il y a pas
besoin d'argile il y a pas besoin de
roches volcanique en réalité les gouttes
d'eau suffisent et ça c'est quand même
une étude qui a grave la classe donc
j'ai pas la prétention de comprendre ça
c'est de la biochimie l'origine de la
vie en général c'est une question de
biochimie j'ai pas la prétention de
comprendre je vous mets l'article en
description
mais en gros ce qu'ils disent c'est que
voilà on n'a pas besoin de tout ça des
gouttelettes d'eau qui s'évaporent ça
suffit en fait la surface des
gouttelettes la tension de surface de
l'eau sur les gouttelettes suffit en
fait à catalyser l'assemblage des acides
aminés et la le fait que la gouttelette
ensuite s'évapore va souder en fait les
acides aminés entre eux et c'est juste
de la folie c'est juste de la folie quoi
en fait tout était tous les ingrédients
étaient là sur terre le lire les comètes
on sait qu'elles ont des acides aminés
on le sait depuis longtemps que les
comètes que les ses objets stellaires de
manière générale qui formait le système
solaire primitif avait des acides aminés
donc il y avait des acides aminés sur
terre ça on le sait déjà et maintenant
on sait grâce à cet article qu'en fait
il y a pas il y a besoin de rien pour
qu'il s'assemble pour former des
protoprotéines donc des peptides c'est
ce qu'ils appellent des des isomères
peptidiques donc des protoprotéines et
ça a besoin de rien ça il y a besoin de
littéralement de rien l'argument
passionniste de il faut des protéines
pour synthétiser des protéines donc la
vie la popu apparaître toute seule il
s'effondre complètement cet argument il
y a besoin de rien de l'eau et des
acides aminés point barre ces prodigieux
j'adore j'adore je suis fan et puis ça
taux article qui est aussi enlève une
autre épine du pied de la de la théorie
de l'évolution c'est la comment qu'on
crée des nouveaux gènes et enfin est-ce
que et les créationsnistes évidemment
vous vous demanderont mais montre-moi un
nouveau gène vas-y vas-y montre-moi là
comment ça apparaît un nouveau gène bah
cet article fait voilà des nouveaux
gènes apparus chez l'humain en plus
alors là c'est pour les
créationsnistes en PLS c'est caviar donc
la naissance des novo donc de nouveaux
gènes enfin de nouvelles protéines
fonctionnelles dans la lignée humaine
donc c'est protéines fonctionnelles qui
sont créées à partir de gènes qui
apparaissent spontanément dans des
séances dans des séquences non codantes
alors là je dis chapeau encore une fois
pas la prétention de comprendre tout
l'article difficilement je peux
difficilement émettre un avis critique
mais si c'est vrai bah c'est hyper cut
uppercut de droite direct dans la face
des créationsnistes et très honnêtement
je préfère croire ce qui est dit dans
sell report ce qui est un journal très
prestigieux de la série de la série des
selles de selpress que les que les
arguments sortis de nulle part des
créationsnistes voilà c'était pas
léonieuse je vous remercie de l'avoir
suivi n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour
ne rien manquer d'anciens et je vous dis
à très bientôt
[Musique]